ce avec notre fil rouge de la soirée on
s'est inspiré d'un prendre brésilien qui
nous a fait beaucoup rire au cours de
l'enregistrement du prime des années
2000 on a fait croire aux chroniqueurs
qu'on allait les incruster en 3d dans le
clip de leur chanson préférée chose que
ce tournage n'a jamais eu lieu
d'habitude on les a plongés dans un
ascenseur où se trouvait un comédien au
transit un [ __ ] qu'on peut regarder la
première avec caroline ithurbide je vous
le dis là c'est bar de rien
[Musique]
je chante
j'arrivais de neige bons et parce que
c'est toujours
vas-y c'est au cinquième moi je vais je
vais voir s'il y en a d'autres
chroniqueurs qui arrive je vais jusqu'à
la prod uccello pas de souci non
t'inquiète pas non non on fait pas
paniqué je suis un peu claustro dans les
assurances alors commencé par émettre la
panique oui ça sent la mousse à raser
maintenant on commence par se casser
parce que moi non plus je suis
claustrophobe pas possible alors si tu
t'amuses amour et sérieux nom et votre
joie je vais pas rigoler vente amuse pas
un cri est comme ça ça va pas ou quoi
[ __ ] on pour lui il faut même pas dans
ses rangs commencent pas à faire des
trucs comme ça
manon doucement doucement de cette rue
crient même pas comme ça [ __ ] [ __ ]
en bus rien de précis fric en plus j'ai
envie de lâcher une ses caisses moi je
suis pas un gastro une diète obtient
franchement je suis pas bien désolé si
je fais un holà au [ __ ] j'suis désolé
[ __ ]
désolé
oh
mais
tu m'avais ne sont pas du tout toxico
magritte la porte car olivier biffaud
l'emballage avec ton voile replay s'est
regardé dans les paires gagné bravo moi
le replay de caroline ithurbide s'il
vous plaît merci que berregard airs de
l'explosion la peau non mais lol ah là
là bas et maxime gagné nous a rejoint
maxime kenya été victimes aussi du cac
ascenseur oui le mec était celle où
ouais bah oui bon là c'est pas si je
voulais voir ce match gagné dans
l'ascenseur ah oui oui regardez
oh
[Musique]
tous cas
brousseau 5
vas-y maxime a tout à l'heure vous allez
aux comptes c'est le sommet du tout je
fais un courrier et c'est dans le
bâtiment société ouais un truc quoi
susciter la trois dimensions on va faire
un film tu fais là oui on va jouer dans
freud ils ont la logique c'est sympa le
clip de la classe conseiller pas pu tous
ces trucs
franchement où les trucs parce que moi
je suis quelqu'un de très claustro je
perds pas de temps sur ces trucs-là
j'appelle direct les trucs en plus je
suis pas bien du coup une petite gastro
là je suis désolé mais diarrhée de ouf
franchement si je te lâches des caisses
là je suis désolé parce qu'en plus ça me
stresse de ouf
non mais rigole pas franchement là je
suis pas bien gros vraiment vraiment 3 3
c'est là je vais me est aussi je suis
[Musique]
et
ils ont l'habitude à regarder la tête et
de matinée moi cette tête et dans leur
maxime tiens ya cru un toucher doux et
j'ai essayé de le mettre dans la poche
ou dans le bus contractant de rang dans
l'ascenseur est ma seule crainte c'était
l'odeur j'ai peur que l'odeur reste
infiniment sur moi mais vite scène je me
suis rendu compte que ça sentait le
chocolat merci la série que c'est mieux
que c'est ouest et du chocolat
vous aviez vous avez l'habitude